le vent de l'histoire a soufflé sur
kiribati
en 1943 les forces américaines lancent
une vaste offensive pour venir à bout de
l'armée japonaise
sur les plages de tarawa l'île la plus
importante du pays les traces de ce
passé douloureux sont encore apparentes
[Musique]
mais la guerre du pacifique est
désormais rangé au registre des
souvenirs
l'avenir du pays est incarnée par une
école qui forme des marrants pour les
navires du monde entier le marine
training center l'école du large accueil
de jeunes élèves en provenance de tout
l'archipel des kiribati
[Musique]
un an de formation avant d'embarquer sur
des cargos qui vont sillonner le monde
entier
[Musique]
le rituel militaire qui ouvre chaque
journée de cours n'a rien d'un folklore
inutile le capitaine bord au vétéran de
la marine marchande et directeur de
l'école insiste même pour que ce
cérémonial soit renforcée
[Musique]
linder on prépare les jeunes d'ici à
découvrir un autre monde un monde
moderne la plupart d'entre eux viennent
d'île où il n'avait ni télévision ni
radio ni électricité
et pour le choc est assez brutal quand
il quitte l'école pour rejoindre les
cargos et qu'il découvre un nouveau
pour les gens d'ici le temps n'a aucune
espèce d'importance pour eux la seule
chose qui compte c'est l'heure à
laquelle le soleil se lève et l'heure à
laquelle ils se cachent quand ils
arrivent à l'école on doit leur
apprendre que chaque minute chaque
seconde compte parce que l'industrie
maritime d'aujourd'hui n'autorise aucun
retard
[Musique]
l'école a ouvert ses portes il ya 40 ans
presque par hasard des marins allemands
de passage à tarawa remarque les
qualités exceptionnelles des navigateurs
de la région il décide alors de former
sur place une main d'oeuvre locale qui
complètera leur équipage une aubaine
pour un des pays les plus isolés du
monde
[Musique]
la république de kiribati regroupe une
quarantaine ville dispersés sur un
territoire maritime de plus de trois
millions et demi de kilomètres carrés
près de six fois la superficie de la
france
tarawa la capitale réunis la moitié de
la population du pays
elle accueille sans cesse de nouveaux
habitants des hommes et des femmes qui
viennent avec leurs enfants tenter de
gagner leur vie en monnayant le fruit de
leur travail
[Musique]
routes goudronnées commerce
communication avec le monde extérieur la
capitale est le seul endroit de kiribati
qui offre quelques signes de
développement
ancien pensionnaire de l'école ite kiro
a passé plus de 20 ans en mer avant de
devenir un des instructeurs du centre
quand on est sur le point de larguer le
bateau de sauvetage surtout ne mâchait
rien pas de chewing gum comme moi ok est
rentré bien vos langues dans vos bouches
sinon vous n'aurez plus longue d'accord
cardiaque
on
se prépare au largage du bateau de
sauvetage terminées
[Rires]
les gars ne soyez pas nerveux du nous
protège allez on y va
[Musique]
je répète on embarque on entre dans le
bateau de sauvetage pour derniers
préparatifs avant la chute libre terminé
henri intégré l'école il ya neuf mois
déjà il fait partie des élèves qui en
terminent avec leur formation les cours
deviennent maintenant des exercices
grandeur nature
très messieurs attention lagajan trois
secondes allez accrochez vous
[Musique]
quand je suis entré dans le bateau
j'étais un peu nerveux j'ai eu un
instant de panique et puis j'ai été très
choqué au moment de l'impact
on est en conditions réelles ils ont à
99 9%
sauf que la chute depuis un navire est
encore plus hot entre six et dix mètres
de plus non c'est exactement la même
chose
pendant que les élèves suivent leur
formation beau rôle directeur de l'école
prépare la sortie de ceux qui ont déjà
obtenu leur diplôme
la sarthe pacifique marines et v6 est
une agence de placement allemande est la
partie aux armateurs qui ont créé
l'école en liaison quotidienne avec
hambourg elle sait quels sont les
bateaux qui vont appareiller et quels
sont les postes à pourvoir
dis-moi peter on a 44 cas prêt à
rejoindre les navires à la fin du mois
il faudrait qu'on puisse les envoyer
rapidement quelque part pour leur éviter
d'attendre ici sans rien faire à la fin
de leur formation
un marc tu as des stagiaires pont et
machines ouais c'est ça on en a 44
il ya pas mal de navires qui ont des
demandes
il ya le cas pas saoul qui a besoin de
deux stagiaires pont fin avril
il ya aussi deux caps san antonio qui
cherche deux stagiaires machine pour la
mi-avril
et la liste continue
en ce moment tout mon avis ont des
demandes
ça veut dire qu'on va pouvoir envoyer
tous les élèves en stage d'ici trois
mois c'est une très bonne nouvelle
[Musique]
kiribati vie de la mère le pays dans sa
zone de pêche et depuis un an il
commercialise aussi son pavillon de
complaisance
mais une de ses principales ressources
restent l'exportation de ses marins plus
d'un millier d'anciens élèves de l'école
de tarawa parcourt le monde
les reversements de leur salaire ici
représente une manne providentielle
chaque année 6 millions d'euros entre 20
et 25% du produit national brut
le marine training center a encore de
beaux jours devant lui
[Musique]
la tôle d'abba yang est située à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres au nord de
tarawa
comme ça marois la plupart des habitants
n'ont jamais mis les pieds dans la
capitale
à 23 ans sa marois a abandonné ses
études il se lève tous les matins pour
accompagner son père à la pêche avant de
lui prêter main forte dans le jardin
[Musique]
ils ne sont pas trop de deux pour faire
vivre une famille de huit enfants
[Musique]
la teneur
je me suis un peu lassé de cette villa
le travail de tous les jours et parfois
ennuyeux
j'aimerais faire autre chose
[Musique]
je voudrais pouvoir partir pour gagner
de l'argent
je voudrais pouvoir aider ma famille
pour qu'elle n'ait plus à travailler
aussi dur pour vivre
[Musique]
il a dit
que oui
comme toutes les îles reculées à bayeux
par est ignoré le monde qui l'entourent
mais les quelques récits de ceux qui
sont partis ont marqué les esprits les
jeunes savent que l'école navale de
tarawa est la seule institution qui peut
leur offrir une nouvelle vie
m
[Musique]
une fois oui non
ils attendent régulièrement le passage
des recruteurs du marine training center
pour se présenter à l'examen d'entrée
leur venue est annoncée sur les ondes de
radio kiribati
aujourd'hui à baï andreu soit rima un
des instructeurs de l'école les chefs
coutumiers de l'île ont prévenu les
jeunes candidats au départ
[Musique]
c'est sous le manet à bas la maison
commune du village qu'ont lieu les
épreuves de sélection
pour sam aloi le rendez vous est
important
on recrute dans toutes les îles de
kiribati
la plus lointaine c'est christmas island
et elle il faut environ une semaine
voire un peu plus en fonction du temps
pour y aller en bateau
maiana et abat yang sont les îles les
plus proches de tarawa la capitale où se
trouve l'école
le nombre d'élèves qu'on recrute dans
chaque il dépend du nombre d'habitants
il y à un système de quotas qui a été
mise en place par le ministère du
travail
les élèves qu'on recrute doivent être en
bonne santé mais il faut aussi qu'ils
aient une tête bien faite on leur fait
passer des tests de mater d'anglais et
bien évidemment aussi des tests
physiques
[Musique]
il faudra près de trois semaines pour
que les tests de recrutement et lieu
dans toutes les îles de kiribati les
instructeurs feront le tour de
l'archipel pour donner leur chance à
tous les habitants y compris à ceux des
îles les plus retirés
trois semaines d'attentes pour les
candidats avant de connaître le résultat
d'un examen qui pourrait changer leur
vie
ça marois espère quitter son île pour
devenir lui aussi marin et embarquer à
son tour sur des navires au long cours
attendu à carros
[Musique]
quand il n'est pas en tournée de
recrutement rima donne des cours de
navigation réservé aux meilleurs élèves
sous qui auront peut-être une chance de
devenir un jour capitaine
henry le matricule 86,02 en fait partie
86 02 est actuellement sur le port de
houston au texas ils effectuent des
manoeuvres d'entrer dans le port
le navire est un temps caire de taille
moyenne
dans les derniers mois de l'instruction
on se concentre sur les stages pratiques
et 86 02 fait partie des meilleurs
éléments
[Musique]
une
dans quelques mois henry en aura fini
avec ses études et comme tous les élèves
il est assuré de trouver un poste sur un
navire allemand
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à vraiment vouloir devenir
marin quand j'ai fini le collège
je voulais voyager et j'ai pensé que ma
seule chance d'y parvenir serait de
devenir marin
pour explorer le monde
mon oncle et marin et il me racontait
toujours des histoires quand il revenait
ici celui qui m'a donné envie
[Musique]
j'aimerais devenir capitaine de navire
un jour
si c'est possible
[Musique]
m à l'école les marins du pays
remplacent peu à peu les instructeurs
étrangers
dans un an et et quiero sera le premier
local à devenir directeur
[Musique]
un exemple pour tous les gamins de
kiribati qui rêvent leur destin en mer
[Musique]
rés
des gestes et aux rires ces ouvriers
ouvriers à des ja
on était tous les deux à l'école
ensemble à nos gonnot nous venons de la
même île
pendant que je continuais mais qu il
avait déjà rejoint l'école navale il est
plus expérimenté que moi comme marin
je voulais gagner de l'argent pour voir
ce que la vie pouvait m'offrir pour
améliorer ma vie
je suis marié
ma femme accepte ce que nous avons
convenu ensemble
et
elle accepte de vivre avec mes parents
pendant que je suis en mer
malgré les contraintes que ma famille il
lui impose
t elle le fait pour moi parce qu'elle ne
veut pas que je sois triste et puis
aussi pour que je continue à travailler
sans me faire de souci
mais il ya aussi certaines femmes
aujourd'hui qu'ils veulent le tout
changer elles ne font que ce qu'elles
veulent c'est plus comme avant non et
oui c'est la nouvelle génération
[Musique]
une nouvelle génération de jeunes femmes
aspirent à gagner un peu d'indépendance
et à kiribati ce vent de liberté divise
les esprits
[Musique]
il y a deux ans l'école a ouvert ses
portes à une promotion de filles mais
l'expérience a tourné court
parmi les 23 qui ont été embarqués sur
les cargos neufs sont revenues enceinte
une a été violée et une autre s'est
suicidé
la préparation des filles aux métiers de
la marine marchande a été suspendu
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
à la place l'école propose des
programmes pour former les jeunes filles
à travailler sur les navires de
croisière un environnement jugé plus
approprié pour elle
les autorités du pays et la direction de
l'école espère obtenir plus de succès
avec ce type de formation
une façon pour kiribati d'offrir une
place meilleur aux femmes souvent
marginalisés voire exclu dans la société
à l'image des cours aux coréens les
prostituées du port de tarawa
[Musique]
ces jeunes filles attirées par les
navires de commerce qui font escale sur
leur route entre l'australie et l'asie
du sud-est ont entre 20 et 30 ans elles
se vendent sur les cargos pour quelques
bières et un peu d'argent de poche
entre le poids de la tradition locale et
la violence domestique
les filles de kiribati ont la vie dure
certaines coraux correa disent même se
sentir mieux considérés par ce qu'elles
appellent leurs boyfriends de passage
que par les garçons du pays
75 nouveaux élèves ont été retenues pour
suivre la formation de l'école navale
pendant un an ils seront pensionnaires
sam raimi rapidement du terrain depuis
deux ans l'école dispense des cours
obligatoires de prévention
certaines personnes disent qu'on peut
mettre de préservatifs en même temps
pendant les relations sexuelles
puisque c'est correct
non ce n'est pas une chose à faire une
autre question
sur le port de tarawa des marins à
l'escale rejoignent leur embarcation ils
ont débarqué leur cargaison et dans
quelques heures ils reprendront la mer
pour rim un le voyage est fini avec
l'argent qu'il a gagné lorsqu'il était
marin il a pu se faire construire une
maison où il vit avec sa femme son fils
sa mère et la famille de sa soeur à 47
ans il a décidé de raccrocher
j'ai vu jérusalem j'ai vu la mer morte
j'ai vu tellement d'endroits dont
j'avais entendu parler quand j'étais
petit à l'école
tout d'un coup tu te retrouve là-bas et
tu vois vraiment ce que c'est c'est ce
qu'il ya de bien dans ce métier
[Musique]
j'ai décidé d'arrêter parce que je
deviens vieux j'ai un fils j'ai une
femme et c'est devenu trop dur de les
quitter pendant onze mois par an
aujourd'hui je préfère être ici qu'en
mer
je ne regrette pas mes voyages j'aurais
pu continuer mais ce n'est que de
l'argent et je ne veux pas être riche
moi je veux juste vivre
les élèves de l'école du large
embarqueront bientôt pour hambourg
après eux d'autres générations
quitteront à leur tour le pays pour
faire vivre leurs familles et s'inventer
une autre vie loin de kiribati
ici tout le monde envie le sort de ceux
qui entrent aux marines jenning center
on les appelle les lucky number
les numéros de la chance